Guten Morgen Thomas. Ich spüre seisfrische Wellen.
Live-Berichterstattung aus dem Epizentrum.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer zweihundertvierzehn jetzt in äh dichter Schlagzahl äh nachdem wir kurz Pause gemacht haben kommen jetzt sozusagen alle
alle schon längere geplanten Termine äh auf einmal hintereinander alle zusammen
Ja und ihr habt schon mitbekommen, ich äh habe heute auch mal wieder einen alten Vertrauten in die Sendung gebeten, nämlich den Thomas, Thomas Loninger, hallo Thomas.
Hallo.
Genau, aus Wien wieder mal, ne.
Ja, direkt aus dem Epizentrum. Ähm unser Büro.
Erklär doch mal gleich mal was äh was damit jetzt auf sich hat. Wo kommt der Name jetzt her.
Ja, der AKAVAT Österreich hat sich unbenannt zu Epicenter Works. Äh, Hintergrund war einfach das Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Arbeitskreis irgendwie nicht mehr so ganz ausdrücken, was wir machen.
Ähm und nachdem wir in Österreich ja seit zweitausendvierzehn dank unserer Klage keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung mehr haben und auch ganz viel
andere Netzpolitik wie Netzneutralität machen, hat's einen neuen Namen gebraucht und wir sind dann zu epicenterworks gekommen, weil das irgendwie gut ausdrückt, ja,
Epizentrum, Schockwellen, was die Netzpolitik so mit der Gesellschaft macht und Works, weil ähm wir funktionieren, wir ganz viel arbeiten und die Kampagnen, die wir machen, äh wirklich immer versuchen in Schwarze zu treffen.
Es wirkt hoffentlich, was wir tun.
Ja und deswegen neuer Name, aber genau selber vereinen und selbe Leute und ja inzwischen sind wir auch schon ein wirkliches Büro mit äh einigen ähm Kollegen und ähm arbeiten ganz brav an dem Chaos, dass auch ihr immer wieder besprecht.
Also das Epizentrum stellt sich quasi neu auf für breitere Themenvielfalt, die er ohnehin ja schon immer hattet. Und mit dem Namen natürlich auch so ein bisschen internationaler, ne, wenn ich das richtig rauslese.
Ja, das war uns auch wichtig, einen englischen Namen zu haben, weil in Wirklichkeit gerade wenn man in Österreich ist. Das ist so ein kleines Land, dass man ähm
ja von vornherein nach außen schaut, einerseits nach Deutschland, aber eben auch dann nach Brüssel. Ähm und wir arbeiten auch die Hälfte unserer Zeit an internationalen Themen
der Großteil der Netzpolitik wird heute ja schon in Brüssel gemacht und deswegen muss man dort präsent sein und mitarbeiten und ja das versuchen wir mit dem neuen Namen zum Ausdruck zu bringen.
Jetzt interessiert mich natürlich auch, ähm wie vielleicht auch so viele andere, weil man's ja dann äh oft auch nicht so richtig mitbekommt, wenn man nicht gerade äh seine Hände sowieso schon drin badet, wie sich so die politische äh Situation, die gesamte politische Gemengelage eigentlich verändert hat, seitdem ihr ja
ähm mit sowohl dem Wechsel des Bundeskanzlers als auch mit dem neuen Bundespräsidenten und dem ganzen Hickhacks äh
der um diese ganze Wahl herum sich da abgezeichnet hat wie wie sich sagen wir mal so die politischen Realitäten da entwickelt haben.
Ja, also wir hatten eigentlich gefühlt äh jahrelang, äh ich glaube
es war auch über ein Jahr Wahlkampf, ähm, weil der Bundespräsidentschaftswahlkampf in der ersten Runde ja so ausgegangen ist, dass keines keiner der Großparteien mehr an die Stichwahl kam
Es war nur noch der Grüne und der äh FPÖ-Kandidat übrig
Norbert Hofer und von Nabellen. Ähm Norbert Hufer eben so schlagender Burschenschaftler und
geistige Vater des Parteiprogramms der FPÖ und Alexander van Nabellen, der kettenrauchende Wirtschaftsprofessor und äh eigentlich auch großer Sympathieträger bei den ähm.
Dann hatten wir irgendwie die erste Stichwahl zwischen den beiden, wo von der Bällen gewann
Die wurde aufgehoben, ähm weil es da Unregelmäßigkeiten gab und sich viele Gemeinden nicht an die Wahlordnung erhalten haben. Da sind die Leute halt irgendwie nicht gekommen, nicht gegangen und haben trotzdem unterschrieben, dass alles
korrekt laut Gesetz abgelaufen ist, dann wurde die Wahl wiederholt und bevor sie wiederholt werden konnte, wurde sie abgesagt
weil wir ähm ein Problem hatten mit dem Briefkuverts, äh für die Briefwahl äh die haben nicht richtig geklebt,
und äh das war dann irgendwie so der super Gau und super peinlich äh zurückgetreten ist niemand, äh wie das so üblich ist in Österreich unter den Politikern.
Und dann gab's eben.
Ja.
Ja, kann ja jedem passieren. War ja deutscher Kleber, ja, eine der Fuhren fürs Klebers kam aus Deutschland, wurde da extra nochmal rausgestrichen bei der Pressekonferenz.
Höhere Gewalt.
Und dann im letzten Dezember hatten wir den dritten
Durchgang dieser Stichwahl, der aber wieder und zwar noch deutlicher für Alexander von der Bellen, den Grünen Kandidaten ausgegangen ist und ähm damit äh haben wir jetzt einen neuen Bundespräsidenten, der auch.
Unterschied zu seinen Gegenkandidaten ganz klar pro europäisch ist, ähm.
Für ein vielfältiges multikulturelles Österreich steht in Mitten Europas und mit,
Botschaft eben äh sich durchsetzen konnte. Das das wurde auch gefeiert als Hoffnungssignal, gerade eben so nach Brexit, nach Trump hat man das ja gebraucht, ähnlich so wie jetzt äh.
Genau.
Genau, das, ich glaube, da wird jetzt jeder einzelne Wahl gefeiert, wo pro-europäische Politiker sich noch durchsetzen können.
Der große Test ist natürlich Frankreich, der steht uns noch bevor.
Ja und der ganz Große ist Deutschland.
Jahr, auch wobei da
Die AfD wird jetzt nicht in Regierungsbeteiligung kommen. Das ist ja aufgrund des Koalitionsmodells in Deutschland die Gefahr ist da, dass sie stark werden. Ähm das wird als Österreicher kenne ich ja rechtspopulistische Parteien. Wir haben mit der FPÖ so etwas schon seit
vielen Jahrzehnten, aber ähm es ist jetzt nicht so wie in Frankreich, dass die wirkliche Angst besteht, dass dass äh Frauke Petry Kanzlerin wird.
Nee, das sicherlich nicht, aber ähm da.
Um eine äh Verschlechterung der allgemeinen Diskussionskultur et cetera zu bewirken wäre halt ein ein großer Wahlerfolg der AfD sicherlich schon problematisch genug zumal er eben auch dieses Koalitionsgefüge
ohnehin spürbar äh stören kann. Allein das mal Deutschland vielleicht von dieser großer Koalition wegkommt, wäre schon mal,
ganz interessant, aber umso mehr das natürlich aufsplittert, noch mehr Parteien und Fraktionen umso schwieriger wird ist, ne. Na gut, aber reden wir nicht über Deutschland. Bleiben wir nochmal bei Österreich. Die Bundesregierung mit dem
Kanzlerkern, wie hat die sich denn geschlagen, weil die war ja im Prinzip dann auch neu, also wenn neu in einem F.
Ja, das haben wir jetzt kurz äh ausgelassen, also während dieser Bundespräsidentschaftswahl dieser nicht enden wollenden,
gab's auch einen Kanzlerwechsel. Die sozialdemokratische Partei hat sich ihres langdienenden sehr unbeliebten Kanzlers Werner Falman entledigt und einem
Bahnmanager, äh Christian Kern zum Kanzler gemacht und der ist jetzt eben weiterhin in der großen Koalition
ähm und die haben
dann eben Ende Jenner ein neues Regierungsprogramm vorgestellt. Das war so im Zuge des Reboots der Regierung. Ähm und der.
Dem Versuch sich irgendwie den Mundus eines Neustarts zu geben und jetzt aber wirklich und diesmal wird nicht mehr gestritten. Wir machen ein Regierungsprogramm, das müssen alle Minister unterschreiben und dann,
arbeiten wir, ähm weil das wollen die Leute ja von uns. Das war so irgendwie die Message.
Und in diesem neuen Regierungsprogramm, was am dreißigsten Jänner zweitausendsiebzehn vorgestellt wurde, fand sich auch ein sogenanntes Sicherheitspaket, was aber ein riesiges Überwachungspaket ist,
Und äh als Datenschutzbürgerrechtsorganisation sind wir da,
sehr stark gefordert, aufzuzeigen, was in diesem Gesetz wirklich drinnen steht und ähm wieso uns das einerseits nicht sicherer machen wird, weil der Großteil dieser Maßnahmen ist eigentlich,
Base von dem, was Thomas Demazer in Deutschland in den letzten Monaten und Jahren vorgeschlagen hat. Ähm und ähm,
Gleichzeitig aber wirklich eine enorme Ausweitung von Überwachung, wo überhaupt nicht belegt ist, ob uns irgendeiner dieser Maßnahmen sicherer machen wird.
Ja, äh bevor wir da gleich im Detail drauf äh eingehen, nur nochmal so die Frage, ähm.
Wirkt denn jetzt sozusagen die österreichische Regierung nach wie vor so ein bisschen getrieben von dieser ganzen äh Flüchtlingsdiskussion? Äh ist das quasi eine Folge dessen oder flacht es ab.
Das so sehen, weil also was sind sozusagen die die dominierenden politischen Themen, die jetzt hier hinter dieser Agendabildung stehen könnten.
Ja, gute Frage, also ähm das Ganze.
Sicherheitsthema ist hier sicherlich eines, wo man getrieben wird von der FPÖ, von der rechtspopulistischen Partei in Österreich, die ähm ja immer ganz stark äh ähm darin war, sehr,
heftige Forderungen aufzustellen in Sachen Sicherheits und Asylpolitik und
Das, was man eigentlich immer über die letzten Jahr, Jahrzehnte in Österreich gesehen hat und was ich befürchte, dass auch in Deutschland passieren wird, ist, dass man am Anfang, wenn diese Forderungen von rechts kommen, sagt, oh mein Gott, wie kann man nur und dann gewinnen die Wahlen und
dann übernimmt man irgendwann diese Forderungen und das gesamte politische Spektrum rückt so ein bisschen nach rechts. Ähm ein schönes Beispiel, einer der Kernforderungen der FPÖ war seit vielen vielen Jahren ein Burka und Hitcho
Verschleierungsverbot, wo man natürlich erstmal an muslimische Frauen denkt. Ähm, da waren immer alle dagegen. Und jetzt mit diesem Regierungsprogramm ähm,
ja, es können sich fast alle hinter dieser Forderung stellen. Ähm und äh das ist auch ein Gesetz, was schon in Begutachtung ist. Also,
in Sachen Asylgesetzgebung trifft er das klar nach rechts, aber auch in Sachen Sicherheitsgesetzgebung versucht man dann.
Eigentlich sogar die Rechtspopulisten zu überholen und.
Gerade Sicherheit ist ja ein ein Politikfeld, in dem man noch sehr gut Handlungsfähigkeit simulieren kann. Wo man schön zeigen kann, ja, aber wir haben doch diese und jene Maßnahme gesetzt
Ähm das Ding ist bei Sicherheitsgesetzgebung gibt's eigentlich überhaupt kein Korrektiv, ob das, was man da beschließt, uns irgendwie sicherer macht,
weil wenn dann doch mal ein Anschlag passiert und wir hatten in Österreich ja nur einen Verhindertenanschlag ähm im Jenner, der aber auch das war ein Siebzehnjähriger, der.
Sich seine Waffen für den Anschlag von einem Zwölfjährigen besorgen wollte und angeblich irgendwie Bomben bauen wollte, aber äh wirklich weit weit weg von der Ausführung irgendeiner Tat war.
Und trotzdem war die Reaktion nicht okay, Sicherheit hat funktioniert, wir haben den rechtzeitig geschnappt, noch bevor irgendwas hätte passieren können, sondern die Reaktion war
jetzt brauchen wir noch mehr Kompetenzen, noch mehr
Massenüberwachung ähm und in dieser Logik kann Politiker glaube ich sehr gut persönlich punkten, vor allem ein Innenminister, aber wir sind halt ganz weit weg davon, sinnvolle, faktenbasierte Politik zu machen.
Sinnvolle, faktenbasierte Politik. Also, was man auch unter dem Namen Science-Fiction kennt. Ja
Dann lass uns doch mal kurz auf die Details dieses konkret angesprochenen Überwachungspakets geben, in dem ihr euch jetzt entgegenstellt, was äh was steckt da jetzt alles äh drin an Änderungen ähm,
Wie umfangreich ist das.
Ja also ähm das sind mehrere Themen drinnen. Ich gebe vielleicht mal,
kurzen Abriss. Ähm einerseits die Vernetzung von Videoüberwachungskameras, sowohl ähm öffentliche wie auch private Videokameras sollen an zentraler Stelle vernetzt werden,
Also ähnlich wie das wie die Überwachungsverbesserungsgesetz in Deutschland.
Ja eine unglaubliche Verbesserung, ja? Also das muss man ja auch mal sagen.
Hier steht noch nirgends Verbesserungsgesetz dran.
Kommt auch noch. Das kommt bestimmt noch.
Dass das Interessante hier ist, dass diese übern diese Vernetzung auch in Echtzeit
passieren soll, was natürlich dann auch eine eine Echtzeitauswertung dieser Bilder naheliegt. Ähm
Die entsprechenden Forschungsprojekte gibt schon lange ähm Innenministerium und äh die Befürchtung ist ja einfach, dass man wirklich so ein,
optisches Gebilde baut und ähm alle Kameras an öffentlichen Plätzen, Bahnhöfen, Verwaltungsgebäuden und großen Firmen an zentraler Stelle vernetz,
was äh einerseits natürlich ein riesiger Eingriff in die Privatsphäre von allen Leuten ist. Äh vor allem wenn ich darüber dann Gesichtserkennung laufen lasse oder.
Automatisierte Erkennung von Gefährderinnen, Gefährdern, also wer zu langsam oder zu schnell geht oder irgendwie sich auf einen anderen Menschen komisch zubewegt, ist dann gleich
und vielleicht Gefährder ähm und da sind haben wir haben wir ein großes Problem,
bietet aber auch eben zusammen, die ich mit dem nächsten Punkt Kennzeichenerfassung. Es soll auf allen österreichischen Städten,
äh auf allen österreichischen Straßen. Ähm dort äh wo es schon Kameras gibt, die sie verwendet werden, um die Kennzeichen von allen vorbeifahrenden Autos zu erfassen.
Geht's denn dabei um mobile Installationen oder geht's da um auch äh feste? Und gibt es solche festen Installationen eigentlich in irgendeiner Form.
Es gibt solche festen Installationen zum Teil, ähm es nennt sich Section Control. Ähm das wird aber jetzt wirklich nur sehr punktuell verwendet eigentlich zu Staumessungen. Es gibt manche Anlagen, die ähm
äh fest sind, die äh die Viniette prüfen. Wir haben hier schon eine Autobahnmaut in Öst.
Ah, die, also die wird optisch geprüft.
Genau, die wird optisch geprüft mit eine.
Das heißt, da wird dann sozusagen ohnehin schon das Kennzeichen äh gescannt.
Na ja, die jetzige Basis für diese Verarbeitung ist, dass der wirklich nur schaut.
Dieses Auto eine Vinette, ja nein, ist die Vinette korrekt oder hat der irgendwo hier vielleicht einen Haarriss äh in der Vigette? Falls ja ist die Kamera gut genug, dass sie den,
Haris auf diesem Kleber erkennt beim vorbeifahrenden Auto,
und sofern einer dieser Tests anschlägt, wird das Kennzeichen ausgelesen und dann automatisierten Briefe schickt, äh hey, du hier strafft Mandat, äh deine Vigette ist falsch. Übrigens, hier ist das schöne Foto von deinem Auto von oben. Ähm.
Vorbeifahren auf der Autobahn. Also mit anderen Worten, die Kennzeichen werden alle gescannt. Sie werden halt,
nicht ausgewertet beziehungsweise es wird nichts daraus, es folgt daraus nichts, aber der Scanvorgang als solcher findet statt, genauso wie er das bei den Mautsystemen in Deutschland auch ist, wo es ja eigentlich nur um die LKWs geht
Aber wo man ja alles erstmal scannen muss, um zu gucken, was ist das überhaupt? Also werden die PKW-Daten quasi offiziell wieder fallen gelassen. Also das ist äh immer der Unterschied zwischen Löschen und.
Als gelöscht markieren.
Ja, also die Bilder sind auf jeden Fall da. Die Frage ist, was davon wird jetzt ausgewertet? Und äh es ist halt nochmal ein großer Unterschied, ob ich da jetzt nur Bilddaten habe, die ich nach,
Minuten Stunden lösche, wenn da eine korrekte Viniette dran war oder ob ich von allen Autos die Kennzeichen erfasse und die dann in einer Datenbank gebe, aus der ich Bewegungsprofile.
Von allen Autos auf allen österreichischen Straßen ableiten kann.
Und es ist ganz spannend zu sehen, dass der österreichische Autobahnbetreiber die Asphinag sich sehr vehement gegen diesen Gesetzesvorschlag stellt.
Also deren Unternehmenssprecher war ganz flott dabei zu sagen, also das ist
Das geht technisch mal alles gar nicht. Wir haben gar nicht diese Kameras, äh was ein bissel zweifelhaft ist und dann aber wir wollen da nicht zum die Hilfen der Strafverfolgung werden. Das ist ja auch eine sehr gute Einstellung ist für.
So ein eigentlich staatsnahes Unternehmen sich da auf die Hinterbeine zu stellen und zu sagen, wir wollen hier nicht Hilfsschere fan.
Und ähm da haben wir noch keinen Gesetzesvorschlag zu dem Thema. Das wird sicher sehr spannend, was sie sich hier wirklich einfallen haben lassen, wie flächendeckend diese Kennzeichenerfassung sein soll.
Ob das halt wirklich zu Bewegungsprofilen führen soll oder nur wenn ein Kennzeichen zur Fahndung ausgeschrieben ist zum Beispiel.
Solche Systeme gibt's annähernd schon, das wäre natürlich auch nochmal ein bisschen besser.
Weil dann eben nur die schon wirklich gesuchten Kennzeichen äh wirklich erfasst und weitergeleitet werden
Das Problem hier ist überall so, ähm der Großteil davon ist eigentlich schon Praxis, jetzt wird's so ein bisschen im Nachhinein legalisiert äh und wir müssen uns wirklich äh genau damit beschäftigen,
wieder noch die technische Implementierung ausschaut, weil am Ende ist es eine Zeile kot, ob ich diese Bilder dann auswerte oder lösche ähm und deswegen ist da sicherlich sehr viel Sorgfalt geboten.
Ähm kurze Nachfrage, diese Asphinack, das ist ja quasi das, was wir in Deutschland gesellschaftsöffentlichen Rechts nennen würden, weil sie quasi so Staatseigentum äh verwaltet, betreibt. Richtig?
Das ist ein bisschen kompliziert, weil wir haben glaube ich unter schwarz-blau den Trick angewendet, dass wir die ganzen Schulden für den Autobahnausbau privatisiert haben, indem wir die einer.
Ähm einer Unternehmen äh übergeben haben, wo der Staat glaube ich schon noch Anteile hält. Ähm, welche genau Rechtsform das ist, weiß ich nicht, aber die agieren zumindest sehr autonom als Autobahnbetreiber.
Kümmern sich eben auch um den Ausbau zumindest bei den Bundesstraßen, so weil ich weiß und ähm sind eben auch für Mautthemen verantwortlich.
Okay. Und ist das üblich, dass die sich so politisch ähm positionieren.
Nein. Also das ist eher selten, weil natürlich sind so staatsnahe Unternehmen ähm nicht sommerlicher Picht darauf äh irgendwelchen Ministerien oder der Regierung Konter zu geben.
Schlecht für den persönlichen Werdegang.
Aber trotzdem ist er hier schon so ein Zurückhaltung zu spüren.
Und denkst du, dass das eine eine ähm eine moralische Zurückhaltung ist oder ob hier ähm in irgendeiner Form eine Einschränkung des normalen Autobahnbetriebs befürchtet wird? Kann ich mir eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen.
Also ich glaube, dass das ähm für die.
Autobahn an soll als solche, es ist egal, wer da jetzt irgendwie, ob das voll überwacht oder,
Privatsphäre funktioniert. Ähm ich glaube wirklich, dass die zum Teil moralisch motiviert sind und eben aber auch ein bissel drum füchten, was da ihnen an an Aufgaben vielleicht auch aufgeheißt wird von staatlicher Stelle.
Und vielleicht fühlen sie sich am Ende halt auch als Interessensvertretung für die Autofahrerinnen und Autofahrer. Das ist eh eine Gruppe, die wir hier gerne aktivieren wollen würden, weil so diese Autofahrerclubs sind natürlich eine riesige Lobby.
Und es gibt noch ein anderes Thema, nämlich auch das äh Belauschen im Auto äh soll leichter werden, also so ein Lauschangriff, dass man.
Ein Auto überwacht mit Mikrofon oder eben über Systeme wie theoretisch um zuzuhören was in diesem Auto gesprochen wird
das ist jetzt schon möglich, aber mit
am sehr hohen Strafrahmen und mit hohem Rechtsschutz und das soll gesenkt werden. Also eigentlich schon für kleinere Delikte soll's möglich sein, dass man ein Auto überwacht
und da sind so ein zweites Autofahrerthema aufgrund dessen, wir hoffen, dass wir diese ganzen Autofahrerclubs hier auch auf die Hinterbeine bekommen.
Die werden natürlich ein starker Allianzpartner.
Ja, denke ich auch, dass das äh eine interessante Stoßrichtung ist. Gut, also die Überwachung mit Vernetzung, Kennzeichenerfassung, was es noch in dem Paket.
Lauschal im Griff im Auto hat sie jetzt auch schon erwähnt, genau. Hm.
Genau und um diesen Bereich abzuschließen, es kommt auch eine Ausweispflicht für Busse und Züge,
ähm das heißt im Moment ist es jetzt.
Genau. Ähm also ähm das Ganze ist,
von welcher Seite täume ich das auf? Ähm, eigentlich kommt das aus dem äh Fremdenrecht in Österreich. Ähm der Paragraph hundertelf dort, der besagt einerseits so
wenn du äh Flugzeug oder Schiffsbeförderungsunternehmen bist, dann musst du die Daten deiner
ähm deiner Fahrgäste an die Behörden weiterleiten
Ähm das ist der Grund, wieso man auch bei Schiffen angeben muss, äh wenn da Grenzübertritt geplant ist oder grenznäher befahren wird, äh was für Leute auf diesem Boot sind. Ähm das ist einerseits äh das, was wir als PNA
Fluggastdaten kennen. Äh, das ist die Umsetzung dieser EU-Richtlinie in Österreich. Und dasselbe Paragraph hundertelf Fremdenpolizeigesetz
ist auch der Grund, wieso im Mittelmeer Flüchtlinge sterben, weil das ist auch der selbe Paragraph, der besagt, dass das Beförderungsunternehmen die Person zurückführen muss
äh wenn sie keinen gültigen Aufenthaltstitel oder wie sei in diesem Land hat.
Und dieser Paragraph wird jetzt für Züge und Busse ausgeweitet. Das sehen wir auch in Europa, wie zum Beispiel in Belgien, dass jetzt äh diese PNA-Daten, diese Fluggastdaten auch für Züge erhoben werden.
Und das will Österreich eben auch machen und zwar nicht nur in Grenzregionen. Wir sind sowieso ein kleines Land, das wäre zu bewerkstelligen,
jetzt natürlich auch regionale Verbindungen gibt, aber sehr viel ist ganz nah.
Da will man eben auch, dass man so einen Zug oder Busticket nur noch mit Angabe von Name, Geburtsdatum.
Und vielleicht eben auch hier zeigen eines Ausweises kaufen kann.
Und das sehen wir als großes Problem, weil wenn man sich mal diese Maßnahmen zusammen vorstellt, ich kann weder mit Zug, noch mit Bus, noch mit Auto.
Irgendwie nur noch anonym von A nach B kommen. Äh wenn ich die U-Bahn verwende, bin ich durch diese Videoüberwachung Gesichtserkennung auch schon,
betroffen und damit habe ich eigentlich ein komplettes Panoptikon und ich kann irgendwie nur noch spazieren gehen, wenn ich von Stadt A nach Stadt B gehen will und das nicht in irgendeiner Datenbank aufscheinen soll.
Beunruhigend.
Sehr. Ähm und da merkt man schon irgendwie so diese Tendenz bei diesem ganzen Überwachungspaket. Es geht wirklich darum
alle Menschen in Österreich zu überwachen. Also jeder verliert ein riesiges Stück Privatsphäre durch äh diese Vorschläge. Und deswegen sind wir da auch so stark dagegen, auch wenn das jetzt so in einzelnen kleinen Häppchen daherkommt, das muss man in der Gesamtschau sehen
da bleibt er nicht mehr viel übrig. Wenn ich jetzt sage, ey, ich will,
vielleicht mal anonym auf 'ne Demo gehen, kannst du nicht, weil Verschleierungsverbot, ich will irgendwie anonym zu diesem politischen Treffen in 'ne andere Stadt fahren,
Finde mal einen Weg,
also da sprechen wir schon von einer einer voller Fassung und eigentlich auch einer Vorratsdatenspeicherung von Reisebewegungen und das ist wirklich sehr besorgniserregend.
Ja, das äh klingt alles nicht äh nicht gut.
Ähm die nächste.
Aber ja, du hast noch ein paar Steigerungs äh Optionen, ne.
Es war noch nicht alles. Ähm.
Wenn sie jetzt schon beunruhigt waren, warten sie ab, was jetzt erst kommt.
Behalt diese Hotline äh Stimme im Kopf, darauf kommen wir gleich noch. Ähm.
Ein alter Bekannter, ein Liebling von uns allen. Äh wir mögen ja alle Tiere der Bundestrojaner äh wird auch in Österreich legalisiert nach diesem Gesetzespaket,
so mit dem Titel. Wir müssen doch die internetbasierte Kommunikation überwachen können und.
Es kann doch nicht sein, dass, ne?
Also es darf ja keine Bereiche geben, die sich dem Auge des Staates entziehen, äh doch die hat's immer gegeben. Ähm,
Also so ein äh Bundestrojaner ist in Österreich heute noch illegal. Also es gibt keine Rechtsgrundlage dafür, dass der Staat Spionagesoftware einsetzt, dass äh Ermittlungswerkzeug.
Wir hatten diese Debatte in Österreich schon zweitausendsechzehn. Genau damals wurde so ein Gesetz zum Bundestrojaner vorgeschlagen.
Und da bin ich auch stolz drauf, haben wir es geschafft, äh, schon in der Begutachtung, als dieses Gesetz noch konsolidiert wurde, ähm, so viel Kritik von so vielen verschiedenen Seiten aufzubringen,
und noch ein paar coole Kunstaktionen, dass dieses Gesetz eingestellt wurde. Also ähm wir hatten da wirklich so Aktionen
wo wir ein ein Holzpferd von dem Justizministerium zerlegt haben, wir hatten irgendwie die die technische Universität Wien, die sich kritisch geäußert hat, der Cars Computerclub Wien und wir natürlich auch ähm und durch all die Kritik.
Wurde dieses Gesetz halt wirklich schubladisiert. Der Minister hat sich danach vor die Kameras gestellt und gesagt, ja.
Die Begutachtung war so desaströs, das war schlechte Idee, wir lassen uns was Neues einfall.
Ist das eigentlich ist das eigentlich ein äh akzeptierte Tempologie in Österreich. Schubladisiert, das finde ich ja super das Wort.
Oh ja, das ist ganz.
Das ist su.
Wenn du es nicht weiterverfolgen willst und so, aber es kommt nicht in den Reiswolf.
Wird's schubladisiert.
Ja, wie man sieht, diese Schublade ist auch ernst gemeint, weil wenn dann wieder ein Moment kommt, wie ein Terroranschlag, greifst du in die Schublade rein.
Holen, ne? Genau und das ist natürlich gerade im Zusammenhang mit der äh von dir schon angesprochenen Idee des Lauschangriffs im Auto
ähm natürlich auch ganz interessant, ne? Weil natürlich diese ganze äh wie überwachen wir denn jetzt eigentlich ein System, wo es vielleicht unter Umständen noch nicht vorgesehen ist, wo es aber theoretisch eine äh entsprechende Möglichkeit gäbe, da ja Mikrofone für Freisprecheinrichtungen et cetera vorhanden sind
Ähm und wir auch schon gesehen haben, wie dürfte ich es mit
der Security in aktuellen Autosystemen äh aussieht von älteren Modellen ganz zu schweigen, also alles was irgendwie zumindest schon mal so ein bisschen Internetanschluss hat, aber im Prinzip für die äh neue Bedrohung.
Die wir derzeit ja ablesen können am Internet noch nicht vorbereitet, ist natürlich ein totales Desaster, uns nicht davon auszugehen, dass es in diesen fünf bis zehn Jahren zumindest signifikant ändert
Ja, okay, also der Bundestrojaner ist hier quasi also die die Möglichkeit, das durchzuschlauers, schließe ich, das ist derzeit eigentlich rechtlich in Österreich noch keine,
wirkliche Möglichkeit gibt, einen solchen legal einzusetzen.
Genau, also es gab einen Fall, wo er eingesetzt wurde, aber das war noch aufgrund einer alten Strafprozessordnung. Ähm zweitausendacht
da gab's auch eine Kommission danach, die gesagt hat
ähm das ist ein sehr hartes Instrument und uns sich sehr auch an der deutschen Rechtordnung orientiert hat, also einer Quellenticker U, eine Online-Überwachung ist unter gewissen,
Umständen möglich,
aber eine Online-Durchsuchung, dass ich wirklich auf dem Rechner mir mal anschaue, was sind dort für Fotos, für Adressen, für Kontakte. Das geht gar nicht, das ist nicht verfassungswidrig
Ähm und ähm die Frage ist dann natürlich, wie baust du eine Software, die irgendwie das Skype überwacht, aber eigentlich sonst nicht weiß, welche Dateien auf diesem Rechner sind? Es gib
eine riesige Latte an Problemen mit so einer Software schon allein
du manipulierst ja das Zielsystem. Du musst ja in diesen Rechner eindringen, damit manipulierst du die Beweismittel, die du danach eigentlich vor Gericht ähm verwenden wirst.
Da haben wir auch drauf hingewiesen, dass das in Österreich aufgrund der Rechtsordnung ganz, ganz schwierig ist.
Und am Ende natürlich das, was Linus ist schon öfters ausgeführt hat, dass ab diesem Zeitpunkt, wo es Bundestrojaner gibt, der Staat ja auch ein Interesse daran hat, dass Sicherheitslücken offen bleiben,
dass wir alle unsicherer werden. Ähm und deswegen glauben wir, das geht,
Ganz genau in die falsche Richtung, das wird uns gefährden und nicht sicherer machen und ähm ist auch einfach kein Preis, den man zahlen soll. Man muss damit leben, dass Leute sich auch mal unbeobachtet kommunizieren,
können und deswegen sind wir da ganz klar gegen den Vorschlag.
Ja
Also du wirst wahrscheinlich die Sendung von gestern noch nicht gehört haben, aber das schließt sich äh sehr gut an die Debatte an, die ich hier auch mit Hank Krieger geführt hatte zum Thema Security im Allgemeinen und was da so zuletzt äh vorgefallen ist, unter anderem eben auch diese,
Trojaner und äh KFZ-Überwachungsfrage kam da zur Sprache von dem Desaster, äh was uns allen bevorsteht unter dem Deckmantel IOT mal ganz abgesehen, ne
Wie heißt es immer so schön, dass das Essen IOT steht für Sicherheit.
Der ist gut. Ich will einen Sticker damit. Ähm gut, äh zur nächsten Graslichkeit.
Gut. Bundestrojaner. Was ist noch im Paket?
Ähm so jetzt kommen wir zu sehr.
Ja, zu zwei sehr interessanten Punkten. Einerseits Fußfessel für Unbescholtene. Das werdet ihr aus Deutschland auch kennen, also das wird ja auch dort im BKA-Gesetz, gerade in Deutschland diskutiert oder wenn's nicht schon beschlossen ist.
Also unbescholtene ist natürlich jetzt hier eine eine Definitionssache, ne. Also das wird natürlich in der politischen Debatte nicht so äh parafrasiert.
Ja, sie sagen, äh Fußwechsel für Gefährder äh und.
Fair, da das ist eine.
Genau, aber wer ist ein Gefährder? Ist eine gute Frage, also Fußfessel ist ein Instrument
des Strafvollzugs. Das gibt es für verurteilte Straftäter im Moment als Alternative zum Gefängnis. Damit die irgendwie nicht dem Staat auf der Tasche liegen und von ihm durchgefüttert werden müssen
kriegen sie halt eine Fußfessel, können zu Hause sein, sind aber in ihrer Bewegungsfreiheit eingeschränkt. Also ein klares Haftmittel.
Das will man jetzt verwenden für Gefährder. Wer ist denn ein Gefährder, ein Gefährder ist definitiv niemand, der verurteilt ist. Ein Gefährder ist auch niemand, der verdächtig ist,
Ein Gefährder ist niemand, wo ich einen konkreten Verdacht habe, dass der ähm ein eine Straftatbegehen,
wird oder begangen hat und äh die Spitze des Ganzen ist, in dem Vorschlag der Regierung, heißt es auch, dass eine Fußfessel für abstrakte Gefährder geplant ist. Also das ist die Vorstufe zu Vorstufe.
Strakte Gefährder.
Ja genau ähm und da sind wir ein riesiges Problem, deswegen sagen wir auch unbescholtene, weil das sind nicht verurteilte Menschen,
die hier wie wie verurteilte behandelt werden. Das ist 'ne Aushöhlung der Unschuldsvermutung
man muss sich einfach mal klar machen, wer ist denn ein Gefährder? Wir haben alle dann immer irgendwelche Bilder von ähm äh Islamisten im Kopf, aber ein Gefährder kann jeder sein. Äh das können alle Menschen sein, die sich irgendwie äh kritisch mit dem Staat beschäftigen,
und da sehen wir ein riesiges Problem, weil äh damit einfach die Unschutzvermutung abgeschafft wird,
und ähm da haben wir noch keinen Gesetzesvorschlag zu diesem Thema, aber wir können uns nicht vorstellen, dass das irgendwie verfassungskonform machbar ist ähm uns ähm.
Die große Frage, die man sich immer stellen muss, äh wie hört man denn auf Gefährder zu sein.
Wenn das kein konkreter Verdacht ist, der dazu führt, dass ich auf dieser Liste stehe, was kann ich dann eigentlich tun, um von dieser Liste wieder runterzukommen, um mein Leben zurückzubekommen
Ähm diese No-Fly-Listen aus den USA geben einem bisschen einen Vorgeschmack
äh wie Kafka S sein kann, äh wenn man da irgendwie ins Fadenkreuz kommt und wie wenig Handlungsmöglichkeiten man auch hat, äh sich von so einem Verdacht
von so einem Stigma wieder zu befreien
Äh deswegen wär's ganz wichtig, dass man hier eigentlich sagt, nein, das geht zu absolut gar nicht, weil da einfach äh grundsätzliche rechtsstaatliche Prinzipien gebrochen werden.
Also ich äh kenne natürlich so, weder bin ich Experte in der deutschen Rechtslage, noch äh ist mir die österreichische äh besonders vertraut, aber äh ich könnte mir vorstellen, das ist ja, es gibt ja schon diese grau äh und Übergangsbereiche, sowie äh schutzhaft, also wenn man sozusagen schon so eine konkrete
Anhaltspunkte hat, ja? Für irgendwelche vorbereitenden Maßnahmen, um dann sozusagen zur Verhinderung von etwas
solche Maßnahmenskranken, also wo sozusagen die Alternative zu so etwas tatsächlich eine Inhaftnahme wäre, ja.
Ähm kann ich jetzt nicht genau benennen.
Weiß ich, gibt's in äh Deutschland so einen ganz dünnen Bereich, wo das irgendwie greifen könnte. Das ist ja sozusagen der der äh Diskussionsraum, der sich da zunächst einmal auftut, um diese Fußfesseldiskussionen aufzumachen
aber ich sehe natürlich deinen Punkt. Also, damit wollte ich nur sagen sicherlich lässt es sich auch argumentieren äh hier von,
wenn auch kleinen Zielgruppen zu sprechen.
Die sagen wir mal ein Gefährderstatus haben der schon über das Unbeschuldenheitsbescholdenheitszustand hinausgeht
aber natürlich ist es hier wie bei vielen Sachen, dass man natürlich hier schnell so einen Dammbruch vermutet, dass man sagt, na ja okay, jetzt ne
Mit solchen Begriffen wie abstrakte Gefährder äh erweitert man das Ganze und schafft quasi dann Haftbedingungen für Leute, die unter derzeitigen Rechtslage auf gar keinen Fall
in irgendeiner Form zumindest auch nur zeitweise in Haft genommen werden dürften.
Absolut ähm und äh das ist eben genau diese diese Aushöhlung des Rechtsstaats äh die,
man vielleicht sich auch mal in fünf oder zehn Jahren vorstellen muss, wenn die sozialen Kämpfe
härter werden und es gibt viele Anzeichen dafür, dass das passieren wird, dann kann man all diese Gesetze auch gegen ganz andere gesellschaftliche Gruppen einsetzen und man muss keinen Beistrich dafür ändern.
Ja und vor allem wenn auch so die ähm sagen wir mal die Regierung an sich so ein bisschen auch äh aus einem anderen Lager kommt, die ist äh jetzt nicht so ganz genau und dann hat er
natürlich das perfekte ähm Rechtspaket am Start, um genauso eine Repression dann eben auch durchzuführen. Also, ich würde mir jetzt mal vorstellen, ähm,
Gefängnisinsassen, die die türkische Regierung allein in den letzten halben Jahr so produziert hat, dürfte es wahrscheinlich auch schon mit der Kapazität so eine Sache werden, aber in dem Moment, wo man dann quasi den Rest der Bevölkerung, der einem irgendwie komisch vorkommt, noch mit einer Fußfessel ausstatten kann,
Das werden wir sicherlich auch noch sehen, ne?
Ja und ich meine im Moment äh sind diese Fußfesseln nur etwas, das äh deine deine deinen Standort
äh feststellt, aber es ist ein leichtes, da irgendwie auch noch ein Mikrofon mit einzubauen oder andere Technik, die äh diese Person überwacht. Und gerade eben diese Einschränkung von Privatsphäre als
am Ende ja auch Einschüchterungsmittel. Äh da stellt sich auch die Frage, würde das jetzt ähm einen Anis Amri davon abbringen,
'ne Straftat auszuführen. Also kann man mit diesem Mittel überhaupt Terroristen davon
abhalten, die wirklich ja ihr eigenes Leben in diesem, mit diesem Tatenmoment auch verwirken, ähm dass dann oh okay, dann GPS-Chilfer irgendwie vorher an der falschen Stelle.
Ja gut, dann ist natürlich also gerade der Fall ist natürlich in dem Zusammenhang mit der Fußfessel hier äh wild diskutiert worden. Ich würde sagen, da könnte man auch sogar sogar noch einen Punkt machen, ja? Man hat sozusagen jemanden im Auge, äh der wird da irgendwie über längeren Zeitraum auch schon äh überwacht, also auch konkret B.
Bewacht oder äh zumindest eng überwacht, dann.
Hauptsidenzpflicht in Deutschland, ja?
Ja, genau und genau und dann dann kommt halt beziehungsweise man man kann halt dann sozusagen
aus dieser erhöhten Problemlage, die man bei ihm dann schon sah, ja, könnte man ja auch ableiten
Okay, äh meinetwegen bist du jetzt hier in Deutschland, aber äh was du machst, kommt uns irgendwie ein bisschen äh spanisch vor. Die Frage ist, weil er war ja sozusagen schon,
im Prinzip aus seinem äh auf dem Weg nach draußen. Also er war ja sozusagen schon in Abschiebung. Nur dass die nicht durchgeführt werden konnte.
Wegen dieser üblichen Problematik mit Tunesien in dem Fall spielt er nicht mit. Es liegen nicht die richtigen Papiere davor, et cetera, Pass fehlt. Ja, was halt quasi sich in Klärung befand, also im Prinzip war er ja sozusagen schon.
Aber dann eben dann doch nicht und an der Stelle wäre natürlich diese Fußfessel,
denkbare, sag nicht, muss sein, aber eine denkbare, politische Diskussion äh Option, die äh im Zusammenhang auch diskutiert wurde. Also, wo ich eigentlich hinaus will, ist ganz nicht das Wort reden.
Ich denke, dass es auch sehr wichtig ist für Aktivisten an der Stelle sehr,
gut zu unterscheiden, weil man sich natürlich auch mal schnell in der öffentlichen Debatte ähm in die Ecke gestellt sieht, so nach dem Motto,
Ja, ihr beschützt ja hier nur die Terroristen und ihr beschützt ja den so und wenn man das sozusagen von vornherein alles komplett rausrechnet und sagt so, nee, das sind alles unbescholten, ne? Um diese Argumentation umzudrehen, was ich auch nachvollziehen kann.
Bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, ob man dann immer so den den Durchgriff in der Argumentation auch erhält, den man sich äh vorgestellt hat's mal so als Anmerkung.
Ja, also für uns aufgrund des Texter jetzt vorliegt, können wir nur von unbescholtenen sprechen, weil das eben nur nicht mal Menschen sind, die äh in äh die als Verdächtiger geführt werden.
Und so wie der Text jetzt vorliegt, könnte das auch jeden österreichischen Staatsbürger treffen, der aus der Türkei oder Ägypten zurückkommt.
Wenn wir da ein konkretes Gesetz haben, werden wir das natürlich anpassen, aber im Moment ist es bewusst gewählt, um auf diese Abkehr von der Unschuldsvermutung hinzuweisen.
Und wie gesagt am Ende geht's darum wie das Gesetz konkret geschrieben ist, was die Spanbreite der Maßnahme ist und man muss diese Gesetze immer auch noch Schlechtwetterprinzip lesen, gerade
nach der Türkei, nach Trump, nach Ungarn und Polen.
Man muss sich auch vorstellen, was passiert, wenn genau dieses Gesetz mal in die falschen Hände kommt. Und deswegen ist für uns jetzt wichtig, dass hier mal eine Strafmaßnahme bei Leuten eingesetzt wird, die noch nicht verurteilt sind,
ähm wenn da natürlich jetzt äh unbescholten ist, so die die Zuspitzung davon auf der Kampagnenwebseite ähm aber ich wir sind da auf jeden Fall.
Gespannt, was für ein konkretes Gesetz vorgelegt wird.
So haben wir denn jetzt die Liste schon durch.
Es kommen noch kleine Punkte, einerseits mein die staatsfeindliche Bewegung.
Da geht es dem Vernehmen nach, um sowas wie Freeman und Reichsbürger, also ähm diese neue, häufig äh rechts einzuordnenden.
Bewegungen, die glauben irgendwie, es gibt noch das deutsche Reich und den Deutschland oder Österreicher Staat ablehnen und als Firma sehen, so dieses ganze Gedank.
Äh was ja auch äh an einiger Stelle schon ähm dazu geführt hat. Es gab diesen einen Fall in Deutschland, wo ein Polizist erschossen wurde von von so einem Verrückten.
Ähm und äh in Österreich gab's noch keinen solchen Fall, aber diese Bewegungen sind auch hier aktiv und äh haben auch schon.
Glaube ich ein paar hundert Mitglieder und sind natürlich sehr nervig für die Verwaltung, dadurch dass die gerne sehr
lange Pamphlete dort einbringen und so seitenlange Beschwerden, die dann von den Behörden auch geprüft werden müssen. Deswegen gibt's da jetzt gerade eben so diese,
Gegenwehrreaktion äh mit diesem Gesetz, dass man sagt, ähm.
Wir haben jetzt eben eine staatsfeindliche Bewegung als neuen Straftatbestand definiert und äh wenn man sich dieses Gesetz aber genauer anschaut, dann,
trifft das eben auch wieder, so wie es geschrieben ist, zum Beispiel Leute, die sich gegen äh Bauprojekte, aus Umweltgründen stemmen,
sagen, nein, wir wollen jetzt in Graz kein neues Wasserkraftwerk. Äh wie's gerade der Fall ist und dann vielleicht doch aktiv versuchen, mit Besetzungen, dem Bau zu verhindern, ähm die Heimburger Aubesetzung in Österreich ist so ein historisch wichtiger Fall.
Gründung der Grünen Partei geführt hat, die werden heute Staatsfeinde.
Auch Leute, die sich gegen Asylabschiebungen stellen, werden als Staatsfeinde einzusortieren. Das ist im Grunde jede
Bewegung und wir sprechen hier nicht von Organisation, sondern eine diffusere Bewegung
die staatliche Autorität nicht anerkennt oder äh sich dieses selbst anmaßt äh und den Vollzug.
Von diesen Entscheidungen des Staates oder vom auch kleinen Gemeinden.
Versucht zu verhindern. Also das sind auch Leute, die sich zum Beispiel am Stammtisch über den Bürgermeister aufregen und sich überlegen mit normalen zivilen Ungehorsam,
ein Zeichen zu setzen.
Auch Kunstformen, das was das Zentrum für politische Schönheit zum Beispiel macht, könnte man als staatsfeindliche Bewegung klassifizieren und all diesen Leuten drohen jetzt bis zu zwei Jahren Haftstrafe.
Da wo es dann wirklich äh bedenklich wird ist der Bereich wenn man in die Vorstufe geht. Also wenn ich.
Wenn sich solche Gruppen auf Bücher berufen, auf zum Beispiel irgendwelche Historiker oder Philosophen.
Dann können auch diese Personen, die sozusagen die geistigen Vater davon sind äh mit einem Jahr Haftsprachestrafe belangt werden. Und es geht in den Erläuterungen auch explizit darum.
Die Verbreitung einer Gesinnung einzudämmen.
Solche Meinungsdelikte sind in Österreich neu, sowas hatten wir bisher noch nicht, bis natürlich auf die Verbotsgesetze, ähm aber hier wurde wirklich sozusagen schon allein das.
Verbreiten einer Gesinnung unter Strafe gestellt und das ist auch wieder eine Bestimmung.
Die die aus unserer Sicht gar verfassungswidrig ist und dies eigentlich auch nicht braucht, weil man kann ja solchen,
verrückten Herr werden und sicherlich ist das für die Verwaltung ein gewisser Aufwand, aber das was hier als Mittel gewählt wurde ist einfach weit über dem, was man bräuchte.
Feier. Das klingt nicht gut.
Und überhaupt nicht. Also es gibt auch in dem selben Gesetz äh werden.
Angriffe gegen Beamte jetzt härter bestraft. Ähm! Also es ist so, wenn ich an.
Polizisten oder auch einen Schaffner anrempel, der hat einen leichten Kratzer davon, dann wird das jetzt genauso äh bestraft wie die fahrlässige Tötung mehrerer Menschen.
Also man irgendwie kommen wir in Österreich sowieso immer mehr in so ein Feindstrafrecht, dass sich der Staat versucht gegen ähm seiner Bürger zu wehren.
Dieser Gedanke zieht sich gerade vor allem in der Novelle der Strafgesetzordnung durch und es ist aus unserer Sicht sehr bedenklich.
Oh ja, das auf jeden Fall. Ich meine, genau äh dasselbe läuft ja in Deutschland auch gerade ab, also genauso ein Gesetz ist auch gerade beschlossen worden.
Also wie gesagt, das ist großteils Copy Paste aus Deutschland mit ein bisschen Verzögerung. Ähm,
ein Punkt, der in Österreich zu fast überhaupt keinen Debatten führt, die aber in Deutschland sicherlich ähm heißer diskutiert würde, ist Bundeswehr im Inneren,
Also es soll unter dem Assistenzeinsatz des Bundesheeres innerhalb von Österreich eben sollen mehr Kompetenzen der Polizei
auf das Bundesheer verlagert werden
und wir haben jetzt schon so, dass zum Beispiel alle Botschaften von äh Soldaten bewacht werden, die dann eben auch in normalen Polizeistationen ihre Unterkunft haben,
und wir haben auch den Einsatz von neuen Direktionstechnologien, biometrischen Identitätsfeststellungs äh Technologien äh und da wird auf jeden Fall in dem Bereich mehr ausgebaut
wir haben auch gerade einen äh ehemaligen Polizisten als Verteidigungsminister und da äh passiert gerade eine sehr.
Gefährliche Vermischung von von militärischen und und polizeilichen Aufgaben. Ich ich bin ja recht regelmäßig in Brüssel und,
daher kenne ich das recht gut, wenn man in Brüssel in der Stadt unterwegs ist, sieht man einfach im Alltag Soldaten. Das sind dann irgendwie
junge Burschen in Camouflage mit automatischen Gewähren, die
regelmäßig über Stadtbild verteilt sind und in Wirklichkeit glaube ich, dass das auch der falsche Weg ist, das tut was mit einer Gesellschaft, wenn ich die ganze Zeit schwer bewaffnete Menschen sehe.
Absolut. Ist das sozusagen schon also warum stehen die da.
In Brüssel ist das einfach nach den Anschlägen ähm.
In Brüssel ist es so, Entschuldigung, aber in Österreich ist es noch nicht so okay. Das hatte ich jetzt.
Nein, in Österreich ist es nun nicht so.
Da sind wir zum Glück noch entfernt, also in grenznahen Regionen ähm gibt's natürlich vermehrt äh Soldaten, die äh zum Grenzschutz eingesetzt werden, aber mit diesem Gesetz soll eben auch hier mehr Möglichkeiten geschaffen werden.
Und man muss da einfach klar unterscheiden, also Polizist hat doch eine dreijährige Ausbildung, hat ähm.
Eine eine Grundkenntnis, äh was die Rechtsordnung betrifft, was auch seine eigenen Grenzen betrifft, ist in Deeskalation geschult. All das hat ein Soldat nicht, der ist nach einem halben Jahr fertig, hat trotzdem schwereres und tödlicheres Gerät an sich.
Solche Leute auf einmal mit Aufgaben der inneren Sicherheit zu betrauen ist aus unserer Sicht genau der falsche Weg.
Tja, das klingt alles nicht gut. Aber gibt noch mehr, ne?
Zwei noch, zwei noch. Ähm eine,
eine Sache äh die ist wirklich irrsinnig. Äh kommt so aus dem Telekom-Bereich, äh die Registrierungspflicht für SIM-Karten. Also ähm
heute ist es ja so in Österreich, dass ich einfach zum Supermarkt laufen kann und mir eine Sintrate kaufe äh und mit der dann telefonieren kann, die kann ich aufladen über.
Guthaben äh von von Kreditkarten oder eben auch, was ich so an einer Tankstelle kaufe und damit kann ich anonym telefonieren. Äh wir haben viereinhalb Millionen solcher anonymen Simkraten in Österreich gerade. Laut Zahlen der Regulierungsbehörde,
an die sollen künftig verboten werden. Es muss dann äh nach den Plänen der Regierung.
Jeder der eine SIM-Karte haben will, ähm, seinen Pass herzeigen, sich ausweisen und das ist 'ne Maßnahme.
Schon öfters diskutiert wurde in anderen Ländern und in den meisten von denen abgelehnt wurde. Also so eine Auswärtspflicht für SIM-Karten.
Gab's in Mexiko schon mal und die haben dort dann eben gemerkt, okay, alles was das tut, ist ein Schwarzmarkt für SIM-Karten zu erstellen, deswegen nehmen wir das Gesetz wieder zurück.
Wir haben Dänemark, Tschechien, Neuseeland, Kanada, Rumänien und Großbritannien, die sich alle überlegt haben so ein Gesetz einzuführen und sich dann dagegen entschieden haben.
In Großbritannien sogar nach den Anschlägen von London zweitausendfünf gab's eine eigene Kommission.
Wo nur die ganzen Sicherheitsbehörden drinnen saßen. Die haben sich das angeschaut und gesagt, nein, macht uns nicht sicherer, werden wir nicht tun, führt nur zum Schwarzmarkt. Ähm Cecilia Malms dröhnen, damals noch zweitausendzwölf EU-Innenkommissarin.
Auch mal auf eine parlamentarische Anfrage gesagt, ja Manatorie sind gerade Registration, Summestate, wir haben's uns angeschaut, aber es bringt nix.
Trotzdem, wenn man das jetzt in Österreich einführen.
Und wir sagen auch hier, wo es der Nachweis, dass uns das sicherer machen wird. Ähm, das ist halt eigentlich auch nur wieder so dieses Symbolanlass Gesetzgebung
die aber überhaupt nicht von Fakten getrieben ist und die als Maßnahme einfach klar abzulehnen ist.
Ja.
Der letzte.
Ja, das äh wollte gerade sagen, das klingt ja ähm jetzt ähm zwar alles nicht schön, aber ist immerhin keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Das ist der letzte Punkt. Ähm es soll auch wieder eine Vorra.
Applaus. Natürlich.
In Österreich kommen. Ähm der Grund, wieso ich das hier als letztes und nicht als erstes Thema habe, ist, weil Latin
Texte Regierung. Wir haben hier nur das Regierungsüberwahlen kommen, das Gesetz darauf warten wir gespannt. Aber die nennen das Vorratsdatenspeicherung in Wirklichkeit äh so wie's da drin steht, ist es aber Quickfreeze.
Wo ist der Unterschied? Ähm bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung überwache ich ja.
Die Telefone und äh P-Adressen von allen Menschen in einem Land und speicher die alle für gewissen Zeitraum weg, weil irgendwer von denen vielleicht später mal ähm straffällig werden könnte
Und bei Quickfreeze ist es genau andersrum, ich speichere gar nichts, außer von den Leuten, ähm die,
explizit wo es expliziten Anfangsverdacht gibt
wo ich sage, okay, die Person, die will ich mir jetzt anschauen. Diese Hürde ist am Anfang sehr niedrig. Ähm da kann einfach die die Sicherheitsbehörde hergehen und sagen, von dieser Person bitte ab jetzt alle Daten speichern,
dann um auf die Daten zuzugreifen, brauchen sie aber einen richterlichen Beschluss.
Wenn der Richter diesen Zugriff auf die Daten ablehnt, werden sie gelöscht und die Person wird verpflichtend darüber informiert, dass sie überwacht wurde in diesem Zeitraum.
So wie die das da reinschreiben, wäre das wirklich eben keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung, sondern Quickfreeze. Was in Deutschland ja immer als Alternative diskutiert wurde.
Und wenn wir wirklich dieses Ding so bekommen dann könnten wir damit leben, weil das wäre in manchen Fällen ist es sogar besser, wenn nicht sofort
die Daten beauskunftet werden
sondern wenn man sich zuerst mal irgendwie sagt, wir wollen jetzt mal irgendwie, dass nichts mehr gelöscht wird für Zeitraum sechs Monate maximal
und dann, wenn sich der Verdacht erhärtet, dann holen wir uns die Daten, also es gibt manche Fälle, wo das sogar
Grundrecht schonender sein können, Quickfreest zu haben als das normale Auskunftsverfahren, wie es im Moment existiert
Und wir werden uns dieses Gesetz sehr genau anschauen, ob man da nicht eh wieder äh versucht, Vorratsdatenspeicherung über die Hintertür einzuführen
indem man zum Beispiel die äh Speicherdauer für die Betriebsdaten nomiert, also das, was man für Verrechnungszwecke ja heute schon speichern darf.
Und sollte das aber wirklich nur reines Quickfreet sein, dann wäre Österreich
glaube ich, das erste Land in Europa, was keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung aber Quickfreeze hat. Was irgendwie ein schönes Beispiel wäre.
Ja, so, das Ganze ist jetzt Ende Januar vorgestellt worden, dieses Paket, also das ist sozusagen jetzt erstmal ein ein Plan der Regierung.
Das ist jetzt hat noch keinerlei parlamentarische äh Hürde genommen.
Also es wurden äh schon die ersten Gesetze angebracht, aber eben erst äh zwei von hm wahrscheinlich doch so an neun, zehn, die sie brauchen, um das alles umzusetzen.
Eingebracht im Sinne von ähm jetzt auch schon durch das äh im Parlament diskutiert oder erstmal nur veröffentlicht und das soll dann alles in einem Paket abgestimmt werden.
Also es schaut so aus, als wenn sie lauter kleine Häppchen machen und nicht ein großes Paket
wo sie so als Paket eben präsentiert haben. Also ähm dieses Überwachungspaket haben wir jetzt aufgeschnürt
was wird jetzt passieren? All diese Gesetze werden von den relevanten Ministerien äh in Begutachtung geschickt, dann werden wir natürlich als NGO äh juristische Stellungnahmen dazu abgeben, das
Die haben wir schon die ersten abgegeben. Da kann man auf Epicenter dort works gehen und dann gibt's eine Themenseite zum Überwachungspaket. Da sieht man alle Themen nochmal aufgelistet,
und eben auch unsere juristischen Stellungnahmen, sofern die reinkommen, die müssen sich sehr beeilen, weil in dem Regierungsprogramm gibt's vor allem auch fixe.
Zeit leisten, also bis ähm
März muss alles vorgeschlagen werden, also in Begutachtung gehen und bis Juni wollen sie alle diese Gesetze im Parlament schon verabschiedet haben. Das heißt, sehr kurze Gesetzgebungsperioden ähm und für uns jetzt gerade eben,
maximale Mobilisierung, weil hier gibt's viele Dinge, die wir klar ablehnen und verhindern wollen. Und in diesen ähm paar Monaten, die uns noch bis Ende Juni bleiben, werden wir alles unternehmen,
um diese Gesetze jetzt so so noch zu verhindern.
Ähm und äh wir haben dazu eine neue Kampagne gestartet. Äh WWW Überwachungspaket Punkt AT.
Da kann man sich informieren über diese Themen und auch gleich selber aktiv werden
Wir haben da äh wie es so eben wie üblich ist in in den Kampagnen, die wir tun äh Werkzeuge gebaut, um sich mit den Abgeordneten im Nationalrat in Kontakt zu setzen,
und denen zu sagen, wo ist der Nachweis, dass uns das sicherer macht? Äh diese Maßnahmen sind alle summasumarum ähm abzulehnen. Wir haben hier einzelne Kritikpunkte,
die die man den Abgeordneten mitteilen kann.
Und es geht drum einfach die Sensibilität zu erhöhen und denen klar zu machen, ähm, dass da auf jeden Fall keine Sicherheit in diesem Paket drinnen ist, sondern eigentlich nur Massenüberwachung und.
Es gibt mehrere Möglichkeiten, das zu tun. Klar, man kann irgendwie Social Media verwenden und mit den Abgeordneten zu sprechen oder ihnen eine E-Mail schick.
Aber die große neue Sache, die wir hier gebaut haben, ist eine Hotline, unter der man direkt mit Abgeordneten sprechen kann.
Das ist 'ne Neuentwicklung, also wir haben uns da an amerikanischen Tools Call Congress orientiert und man kann hier einfach 'ne Telefonnummer anrufen.
Und sich dann mit einem Abgeordneten verbinden lassen.
Aber man kann auch eine Anruferinnerung erstellen lassen und dann jeden Wochentag zu einer von sich selbst festgelegten ähm Zeit angerufen werden von uns, um mit einem Abgeordneten verbunden zu werden.
Und ähm ich ich will dazu noch was sagen, weil dieses äh Abgeordnetenanrufen, das ist, glaube ich, wie die meisten Menschen eine ziemlich hohe Hürde. Ähm das ist aber wirklich der effektivste Weg, um.
Bei politischen Themen mitzureden und um wirklich Druck auf die Entscheidungsträger auszuüben. Das macht enorm Eindruck,
Wenn der normale Menschen anrufen, an, man muss mit denen keine elends langen Gespräche führen,
einfach nur zu sagen ich bin gegen dieses Überwachungspaket wo ist der Beleg, dass uns das sicherer machen wird? Das reicht eigentlich schon um die politische Kalkulation zu beeinflussen.
Weil die wissen, dass die Hürde sehr hoch ist und je mehr Menschen wirklich zum Hörer greifen und äh entweder einmal oder eben vielleicht noch zwei, drei Mal, diese Erinnerung kann man jedes Mal weg.
Kann da auch nicht abheben,
anrufen oder einfach äh in dem Menü, was dann kommt, äh zwei Stadt eins wählen. Ähm, wir haben das wirklich sehr User freundlich gemacht, um
es den Leuten so einfach wie möglich zu machen mit ihren Abgeordneten in Kontakt zu treten.
Weil wir kennen das von den europäischen Kampagnen, genau solche Tools braucht's, um wirklich bei den Abgeordneten anzukommen.
Ähm sehe ich das richtig? Ich habe da quasi so eine Art Telefonanlage äh proamiert.
Ja, also wir basieren hier auf Video auf einer ähm API, mit der man recht äh schön eben so Telefonsysteme bauen kann und das ganze Ding ist Open Source
auf Gitter, den das werden wir verlinken,
Äh und die Hotline ist äh null null vier drei für Österreich sieben zwanzig zwanzig fünfzig achtundachtzig.
Rufen Sie jetzt an. Rufen Sie jetzt den Abgeordneten neben ihrer Landesflagge an. Ähm, also wen kriegt man dann da, wenn ich da anrufe? Also wie läuft das dann ab?
Du
Willkommen bei der, bei der Rettung der Welt. Im Efizentrum.
Na, du hast eine eine ähm schöne, schöne äh Radiostimme von jemanden, der uns dann äh.
Der dir mal sagt, ja, herzlich willkommen bei kontaktiere deinem Abgeordneten eine Dienstleistung für die Demokratie von Epicenter Work,
Und dann hat man ein Hauptmenü, wo man sich eben eine
Anruferinnerungen machen kann oder direkt mit einem Abgeordneten sprechen kann, einem zufälligen oder eben einem äh die haben alle eine ID bei uns auf der Webseite, die kann man eingeben und dann ist man direkt mit,
Diesem einen Abgeordneten verbunden. Man kann sich nochmal Argumente vorsagen lassen. Wir haben da eben auch so Infotapes
und äh Feedback gibt's und äh Abmeldung von dieser Anruferinnerung, also es soll wirklich so einfach wie möglich sein. Und wenn man so eine Anruferinnerung hat, ist es vielleicht ein bissel mehr, ist man mehr genau.
Etwas für äh die eigene Demokratie zu tun, weil,
dieses mit von den eigenen Bürgern zu hören, ist gerade in Österreich sehr unüblich
Die Abgeordneten sind's gewohnt, eigentlich isoliert äh in ihrem Parlament arbeiten zu können über diese Themen zu entscheiden. Und vielleicht gibt's mal hier und da eine Bürgerinitiative, die man dann in einem eigenen Ausschuss schubladisieren kann. Aber
eben nicht diese dieser inhaltliche Auseinandersetzung, dass Leute mal wirklich sagen, also ich hab diese und jeder bedenken und ich sehe das so und so.
Aber genau das braucht's, weil Demokratie ist immer die Summe aller Stimmen von Leuten.
Wenn wir diese Stimmen nicht bis zu den Abgeordneten bringen, dann glauben die, es ist eh okay, was sie gerade.
Und stimmen in diesem dieses Mal wirklich im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Also hier geht's äh wirklich dadrum, die Stimmen äh erklären zu lassen. Ich sehe hier auch gerade ganz neue Betätigungsfelder für äh Podcaster hier durch entsprechend äh hochmotivierte Minimumführung. Solche Systeme zum Erfolg zu
zu geleiten.
Wir sind extrem offen für alle Vorschläge. Ähm.
Eins für den Lauschangriff im Auto.
Für die Bundestrojaner oder bist du mir verstehst du mehr auf Fußfesseln.
Für jeden was dabei.
Ähm.
Sehr schön, also äh super super Sache. Ich finde es immer erstaunlich, wie er da äh
Kampagnenmäßig auch neue Maßstäbe äh setzt, insbesondere durch die Ablage der ganzen Entwicklung als Open Source. Ähm das heißt hier
geht jetzt auch nochmal der Ruf an Leute, die sich jetzt nicht unbedingt mit Österreich und äh deren Gesetzgebung im Kern beschäftigen, aber vielleicht für die eigenen Projekte
solche ähnlichen Systeme auch gerne mal an den Start bringen könnten, dann kann man sich das alles bei Gitarr herunterladen und im Prinzip für seine eigenen Bedürfnisse anpassen.
Ganz genau, also freie Lizenz, offener Code, ähm solche Kampagnen-Tools nutzen sich natürlich ab, man muss.
Gezielt sie einsetzen, also das mit dem Faxen, was wir damals im Europaparlament gemacht haben, geht heute nicht mehr, weil die kommen nicht mehr auf Papier raus, sondern einfach in irgendeiner Outl
Mailbooks. Ähm, aber am Telefon ist so 'ne Technologie, die sie jetzt schwer abdringen können
und äh je personalisierter man die Leute kontaktiert, umso besser ist es. Ähm eine E-Mail ähm und vielleicht auch Facebook-Nachrichten kann man noch irgendwie wegfiltern, aber wenn da jetzt wirklich ein Mensch zum anderen spricht, dann dann hat das ein ein äh einen Effekt
auf diese Leute in diesem Parlamenten und alle äh Menschen in Österreich, die das hier hören und die irgendwie eines dieser Themen oder vielleicht zwei oder drei nicht okay finden, äh,
ruft dort an, sagt ihnen das, das macht einen riesigen Unterschied und äh wenn ihr's
nicht tut, dann dürft ihr euch nachher auch nicht beschweren darüber, dass dieses Gesetz so gekommen ist.
Das alte Lied.
Gut, äh, ich denk dazu haben wir alles gesagt, wechseln wir mal unseren Blick kurz nach Europa
Da äh tut sich ja auch mal wieder so einiges im Bereich des äh Coopy Reits, auch so eine Story. Es gibt da ein
Ein neues Proposel, ähm aber damit gibt's auch ein
Problem. Was ist denn das Proposel, was ist denn der Urheberrechtsvorschlag und was ist das Problem, was hier diskutiert wird.
Ja. Kommen wir nach Europa. Ähm ganz äh eigentlich meiner Meinung nach so das wichtigste, netzpolitische Thema auf EU-Ebene gerade, ist das Vermächtnis von Günter Oettinger,
Der Mann ist ja nicht mehr Digitalkommissar aus Gründen, ähm aber er hat im September zweitausendsechzehn noch ein neues Ulberrechtspaket auf den Weg gebracht und da,
Gibt's eigentlich recht viel dazu zu sagen, ich will mich jetzt nie nur auf einen Aspek
konzentrieren. Leistungsschutzrecht wurde, glaube ich, schon debattiert, ähm was Schrankenregelungen sind, hat äh Julia Reder hier schon mal erklärt
gibt aber in diesem Gesetzesvorschlag von Öttinger eine Sache, die uns wirklich ganz massiv beschäftigen sollte und das sind Uploadfilter.
Uploadfilter bedeutet, dass es bei allen Plattformen in Europa.
Die User Generated Content haben, das kann sowas wie Wikipedia sein oder auch E-Learning Plattformen sowas wie YouTube und eigentlich auch jeder andere Idee von Plattformen, wo User frei Content ablohnen können,
all diese Plattformen werden mit diesem Gesetz äh dazu verpflichtet
dass sie ähm äh Content Regionision Technologies einsetzen. Das heißt, dass sie mit Uploads Filter prüfen, ob dieses Bild, dieses Musikstück, dieses Video ähm jetzt gerade gegen das Urheberrecht verstößt oder nicht
Ob dieses Werk schon von irgendjemanden äh als geschützt markiert ist oder nicht.
Dieser Content Record Nishion, Technologies geben dann irgendwie eine von drei Rückmeldungen.
Entweder ja, das darf gepostet werden oder das darf gepostet werden, aber nur wenn du meine Werbung drunter einblendest.
Und das dritte ist, nein, das darf nicht gepostet werden und dann wird dieses Bild, dieses Lied nicht veröffentlicht im europäischen Internet.
Wir kennen solche Technologien schon unter dem Titel Content ID ist 'ne Entwicklung von Google für YouTube
wenn ich bei YouTube heute ein Video hochlade ähm wo ähm irgendjemand meint, das ist mein Urheberrecht, das ist irgendwie
meine Fernsehsendung oder mein Lied wirst du hier gerade hochlädst, dann kann dieser rechte Inhaber über Content die eben sagen
schaltet meine Werbung ein oder nimm dieses Ding komplett vom Netz.
Und das heißt, das wäre sowas wie eine Vorabzensur von jeder Kulturproduktion in Europa. Das Ganze ist auch nur zentralisiert machbar.
Weil es kann ja nicht jeder Plattformbetreiber selber irgendwie alle Inhalte vorrätig haben die irgendwo geschützt sein
könnten, sondern man muss eine zentrale Stelle haben, die ähm dieses dieses Werk dann sozusagen prüft gegen äh die Liste an geschützten Werken. Dadurch gibt es dann auch eine zentrale Stelle
die über jede kulturelle Produktion in Europa Bescheid wüsste
und natürlich man kann hier vielleicht mit Hashes arbeiten, aber kontinuierlich tut das zum Beispiel nicht,
Die schicken ja die schauen ja wirklich auch, ob da irgendwo im Hintergrund noch Musik passiert. Ähm und äh wir reden hier von Artikel dreizehn.
In der Richtlinie des Europäischen Parlaments und Rats über das Urheberrecht im digitalen Binnenmarkt und ähm das ist.
Wenn wir's mal simpel formulieren wollen, genau dieselbe Art von ähm,
Uploadfilter von vorab Zensur, die wir eigentlich nur aus dem russischen oder chinesischen Internet kennen.
Und dass so etwas ernsthaft in Europa vorgeschlagen wird. Es ist eigentlich himmelschreiend. Ich meine, wir haben gerade eine neue Anti-Terror-Richtlinie. Dort gibt es keine Netzzensur, keine also,
äh zumindest keine Uploadfilter für alle äh Plattformen, aber jetzt in diesem Urheberrechtspaket äh ist das drinnen,
und wir wissen alle, wenn solche Techniken mal etabliert sind, ist es ein leichtes, den Zweck zu ändern. Der Function Creep würde einsetzen, wenn so eine Technik da ist und dann sind's halt als nächstes auch terroristische Inhalte äh und vielleicht auch dies und das in Zukunft, die ähm mit so einer Upload-Filter vorab zensiert würden
Und dieses Gesetz wird eben jetzt gerade im EU-Parlament verhandelt,
da gibt's auch die passende Kampagne dazu und zwar save the mean Punkt net. Äh ist von Bits of Freedom. Äh unsere niederländischen Freunden,
die haben da eben auch ein Tool gebaut, wo man äh mit iPhone, mit dem anderen Telefontool, was es in Europa gibt
ähm den Abgeordneten, die Abgeordneten kontaktieren kann, um ihm eben eben auch zu sagen, dass man das nicht richtig findet, dass äh solche Upload-Filter
in Europa gesetzt werden sollen und wir müssen hier auf jeden Fall alle irgendwie aktiv werden, weil wie gesagt, wenn das durchgeht, dann haben wir,
ja, dann ist das Ende erreicht.
Ähm dieses.
Äh also das Ganze soll ja auf eine Richtlinie hinauslaufen, also zur Erinnerung, Richtlinien, das ist äh das, was
quasi auf EU-Ebene beschlossen wird und was dann quasi so ein bisschen die Blaupause ist für künftige
Gesetzesbildung in den Mitgliedsstaaten im Prinzip ist jeder Mitgliedsstaat gezwungen, diese Richtlinien mehr oder weniger
äh bald umzusetzen. Das kann auch mal etwas länger dauern und wenn's zu lange dauert, dann äh räuspert sich die EU da auch nochmal und je nachdem, welchem Themenbereich sich das befindet mehr oder weniger.
Aber im Prinzip wäre das Ganze ja quasi so ein äh ein Gerüst, an dem man auch sein eigenes Urheberrecht äh in den jeweiligen Ländern anpassen müsste, langfristig oder mittelfristig zumindest auch.
Und ähm ja, das würde natürlich hier eine eine Liberalisierung des Urheberrechts, wie wir uns das glaube ich im Wesentlichen eigentlich immer vorgestellt haben, eigentlich komplett entgegenlaufen.
Ja, also ich meine, wir wir sind hier eh von einem den notwendigen Update des Urheberrechts äh noch weit entfernt.
Wirklich versucht mal an die Lebensrealitäten der meisten Menschen anzupassen und an unser aller Medienverhalten und vor allem auch das Potential ausnutzt um um um freies Wissen äh in der Gesellschaft zu verstärken. Also,
Das ist natürlich immer noch ein äh verstaubtes Urheberrecht von vor ein paar hundert Jahren, aber äh es sind wie so kleine Dinge.
Auch noch nicht erfüllt, wie zum Beispiel eben Schrankenregelungen, dass man sagt, das Urheberrecht,
begrenzt, zum Beispiel in Klassenzimmer, in der Schule kann ein Lehrer frei kopieren, ohne dass er sich ums Urheberrecht kümmern soll, äh oder wenn ich etwas zitiere oder wenn ich einer,
von etwas mache, dann äh äh darf ich äh mich äh darf ich das Urheberrecht brechen, ja, wenn ich irgendwie,
äh lustige Persifire, da irgendwie mein eigenes Video daraus mache, äh dann hat der da jetzt irgendwie kein Urheberrechtsanspruch drauf.
Diese Schrankenregelungen gibt's in dieser Richtlinie, aber es sind Kannbestimmungen.
So ist es auch jetzt schon und das führt dazu, dass du in dem einen Land äh darfst du irgendwie Parodie machen, im anderen nicht, in,
im einen Land gibt's Panoramafreiheit, dass du irgendwie von der Straße ein Gebäude fotografieren kannst und der Architekt dieses Foto nicht zensieren kann. Im Anderen
wäre das illegal,
an diese Schrankenregelungen sollten verpflichtet werden, das wäre so das Minimum an äh Verbesserungen im Urheberrecht, dass wir eigentlich bräuchten.
Aber doch das ist jetzt im Moment noch nicht drin. Ähm! Und wie gesagt, wir sind jetzt am Anfang von dem Gesetzgebungsverfahren.
Das Ganze muss erst durch Rat und Parlament durch. Dann geht es in den Trilog,
Das heißt aber wir müssen uns jetzt in der ersten Lesung im Parlament, wo wir historisch immer die besten Karten haben, weil Abgeordnete halt noch eher auf Bürger hören.
Da müssen wir uns alle einbringen oder beziehungsweise äh vorher hatte ich ein Thema für die Österreicher. Jetzt habe ich ein Thema für die Deutschen,
ähm wenn man in Brüssel spricht mit den Leuten und das habe ich ähm letzten letzten Montag gemacht, wie ich dort war, ähm, bei Idrias die Meinung vor, das ist ein deutsches Proposel von einem deutschen Kommissar.
Und äh sowohl im Rat wie auch im Parlament hören viele Leute auf diese Argumente, dass Uploadfilter eine ganz schlechte Idee wäre, aber es sind eben gerade die Deutschen Abgeordneten von SPD und Union.
Die hier noch klar für diesen Vorschlag sind und die eigentlich hier ihre Position ändern müssten, ansonsten gibt's wenig Chancen, dass man dieses äh Proposel nochmal verhindern könnte.
Ein deutsches Problem. Ja und wir haben ja auch durchaus gemerk,
Genau und wir haben ja auch durchaus gemerkt, dass also äh Widerstand gegen solche ähm Richtlinien, Vorschläge der Kommission äh über den äh Weg des Parlaments,
'ne realistische Chance haben. Also es gab auch,
Negative Beispiele, aber es gab auch genauso viel gute Beispiele. Man schaut sich nur die Datenschutzgrundverordnung äh an äh weitere Beispiele könntest du wahrscheinlich nennen. Ich gerade nicht aus dem Kopf, aber Widerstand ist möglich.
Ja, also im Europaparlament haben wir eigentlich recht gute Karten, also das ist auch wirklich das Parlament, mit dem ich am liebsten arbeite, weil Argumente dort was zählen.
Und die Leute, mit denen du dort sprichst, die haben alle ein freies Mandat, die sind nicht unbedingt an ihren Club, an ihrer Partei gebunden, das heißt, wenn ich diesen einen.
Liberalen Sozialdemokraten, Konservativen, die kommen alle überzeugen, wenn die merken, okay, das ist ein Thema, wo,
es öffentliches Interesse gibt, wo es gute Argumente für die eine oder andere Richtung gibt, dann bilden die sich ihre eigene Meinung.
Und das ist eher selten, meistens in den nationalen Parlamenten ist es so.
Dass man die Sprecher der Clubs der Parteien überzeugen muss und die geben die Richtung vor und und was der Einzelne die einzelnen Abgeordneten denken, es ist eigentlich egal. Im Europaparlament gibt's dieses freie Spiel der Kräfte,
und das führt in den meisten Fällen zu besseren Entscheidungen. Und das macht's auch möglich, eben.
Durch diesen persönlichen Kontakt mit Abgeordneten wirklich einen großen Einfluss in die Entscheidung zu haben.
Gut, wie äh also wer engagiert sich hier besonders, also Bits of Freedom haben wir schon äh gehört, Edri hat ja auch hier nochmal eine äh Stellungnahme veröffentlicht dazu. Äh und da.
Gibt's viele, es gibt ein paar äh Videos, die wir verlinken. Wir haben ein gutes äh PayPer, das diese ganze Richtlinie das Gesetz auseinander nimmt und äh Idri ist auf jeden Fall der Hauptansprechpartner ähm für dieses Thema
und ähm man sollte sich dort irgendwie informieren und äh eben bei save the mean Punkt net vorbeischauen und dort ähm auch eben auf den Call Platten klicken, Abgeordnete anrufen,
denen sagen, was man von Upload-Filtern in Europa näht.
Genau, unsere Mime schützt schützt die Mehme.
Bitte.
Früher waren's irgendwelche Vögel. Jetzt sind's.
Komische Bildchen im Internet, aber äh soweit ist es halt mit uns jetzt schon gekommen, ne? Müssen uns um unsere Emojikons äh kümmern.
Es hilft der Emojicon, gute Ide.
Ja Thomas.
Vielen Dank sage ich mal, dass äh sollte glaube ich für diese Ausgabe äh erstmal reichen. Die Lokbuchen jetzt Politikhörer äh werden jetzt ohnehin äh mit Content vollgestopft, nachdem sie erst ähm eine Sendepause beklagt haben.
Kommt mir nicht so, dann dann wird doppelt zurückgezahlt. Nee, aber immer wieder äh schön die äh Einblicke auch aus Österreich und natürlich auch aus Europa.
Hier noch mit reinzubekommen, da wird er doch äh oft sehr fokussiert auf die Vorgänge in Deutschland sind. Da passiert ja auch äh genug.
Epizentrum ähm kann sicherlich auch Unterstützung äh gebrauchen, nehme ich an. Nimmt sicherlich auch Spenden an für eure Aktivität, aber noch lieber wär's äh euch, wenn die Leute tatsächlich sich telefonisch verbinden lassen.
Ja, also äh wir wir leben von Spenden. Ähm das ist der einzige Weg äh unserer Arbeit unabhängig äh machen zu können
Damit finanzieren wir irgendwie den ganzen Betrieb hier und sind ja inzwischen doch schon fünf Leute und wir.
Werden auf jeden Fall die nächsten Monate nichts anderes machen, als uns um dieses Überwachungspaket zu kümmern
Ähm gut, die Netzzentrale gibt's auch immer noch, aber es ist genügend zu tun
und äh solche Gruppen zu unterstützen, wenn wenn man die Arbeit wichtig findet, wobei, wie gesagt, uns geht's vor allem drum, dass die Leute jetzt zum Hörer greifen und ähm.
Selber bei null sieben zwanzig zwanzig fünfzig achtundachtzig anrufen und äh wirklich das ist so der,
jetzt so ein vielleicht als Schlusswort ähm ich mache das jetzt doch schon irgendwie jetzt einige Jahre und ich kann nur sagen äh bei der Demokratie mal eine,
aktivere Rolle zu haben, ist auch wirklich gut für die geistige Gesundheit, weil man weiß einfach, dass man was getan hat, ähm in vielen Fällen kann man auch
mithelfen, dass Entscheidungen besser werden.
Man kriegt nicht immer alles, was man sich gewünscht hat, aber es hat einen Einfluss und äh gerade in so Zeiten, wo das Gesamtgefüge
wirklich ins Diffuser, nicht faktische, sei es gefährliche abdriftet
Es ist wichtig, ähm sich ja selber auch mal so ins ins Gewissen zu gehen und zu schauen, hey, was kann ich eigentlich tun, wo betrifft mich das und
dann dementsprechend selbstbestimmt zu handeln. Das kann ich jedem empfehlen, das damit kann man dann auch irgendwie ruhiger schlafen.
Genau, damit ich ruhiger schlafen kann, klicke ich hier auch gerade mal den äh Spendenbutton und äh ihr Hörer und Hörerinnen, ihr solltet das auch tun und Thomas, dann machen wir Schluss.
Ich sag vielen, vielen äh Dank nach Wien und äh ja. Tschüss an alle Hörer. Bis bald.
Ciao.